um
um okay why
would you say that
father's day doesn't get as much
appreciation as mother's day does
in the media
this is a mad one some women use
father's day for themselves again
they celebrate two days
that's how bad it is
nobody cares about men really that's
i okay it's simply just because the
women gave birth so
that's the biggest thing
90 of women are the the main um parent
for the child so only 10 percent raise
on themselves the kids
but then there's the percentage that are
in two parent households which is like
the other half
right
true
i think men don't really get the
appreciation that they deserve
um
and that's i think partly the reason
would you not say women spend more time
raising kids usually so that's why
naturally and you know man's weight and
he's still helping really much but
raising kids women's i mean he has to
provide
that takes a lot of time it goes towards
it still go just he has to go to work
and get it
but then also i could see that sorry you
could say because he's hardly there
because he's providing yeah so he's
hardly he's only seen but he's he's
behind the scene
doing what he needs to do so
but there are adverts just there's
there's advertisements for father's day
as well but what i'd also say they just
don't really get it's just yeah it's not
crazy it's just not the same like how
mothers days
but then they say that women are more um
they're more into buying and mental so
they so a lot of um
advertisements come up with me because
you're more likely to buy it yeah but
also just as a side note to that is when
it comes to mother's day
men tend to put more effort into making
sure the mom has a special day but then
when it comes to the father's day i
don't think that energy reciprocates how
about this there's in lithuania we
celebrate it's a big celebration women's
day no one celebrates hair
i don't know if you've seen it
women's day
you know what's interesting there's
international women's day it's big in my
country there's even there's violence
against women but there's no violence
against there's no men's day yeah and in
lithuania everyone policemen give women
flowers it's very big and if you don't
bring flowers it's like and what do they
men get on wednesday there's no men's
day that's the thing it doesn't even
exist
why why do our women
why do women think that one of the
reasons we're special
is because we give birth but dogs do it
and we don't think dogs are special
[Music]
maybe it's harder to raise a child than
a puppy
[Laughter]
but then the women wouldn't be special
because men were his kids too no because
you look at what we you know we live in
a capitalist society look at everything
the high-rise buildings the trains and
everything would
mostly built by men and who were giving
back to my women so
i would think
the whole some form of power to be able
to have given back to men that created
all of this
yeah so dogs are nursing had a dog that
build a bridge so
what's what's harder to give birth or
raise a child
um i think you can raise a child
let's say you have to give birth every
year then people do every year for how
long what's harder to give birth every
year to raise a church because you're
still good
every year
it's like you'd still have another 18
years and keep going no raising a child
is
way harder so then by that logic
wouldn't women not be special
yes
well
i think kids are special man or a woman
is just women are still special because
they are all most most of the time
they're involved in the raising of the
child so they give birth they also
involved in raising another child so
yeah
but sorry man
that's awesome i guess it's just because
men can't give birth that's the only
yeah but it's not right
it shouldn't be like but that's but
isn't it interesting like we we put
women on such a pedestal for giving
birth but it's like dogs do it
but then it's only the female dogs
so maybe we should put the female dogs
on the pedals yeah but we don't yeah
it's like
but i think maybe like going back to
before why mother's day is so like more
publicized and celebrated yeah
there's so much more money to make from
buying females gifts like you can buy
them flowers yeah
we don't we don't get guys flowers you
know so it's like oh i think everything
that basically in society is all about
how can we make the most money we could
make the most money right yeah so of
course mother's day is gonna be bigger
why do you think that is like why are
why do we buy gifts for women more than
men
do you think maybe there's just more
things that you can
i guess buy
you you give them a ps5
more smaller things you know like you
can buy a woman like a pair tennis
shoes but then maybe it's only limited
to like shoes games watch ties suits
like
i don't know do men really feel like if
we get you flowers are you gonna be
happy or like if we get you like some
nice earrings are you going to be as
happy or if we take you out to dinner
are you going to be
like
females there i think it's partly due to
female hypergamy that's it because you
guys just love to
take as much games as possible but i i
was going to say something i think
this might be an interesting question to
ask if necessary out in the streets if
men could get if men were given the
choice
to get pregnant and go through the
process how many men would take it
i wouldn't
there you go so this is why wait say
that again so you may well so you if we
had a choice if you could go press a
button and you get pregnant and go
through the whole process nine months
and give birth how many how many men
would want to go through that experience
there you go so that's you that's why
women are special so
they go through it is that a
heterosexual men or or no i'm just
saying you know like you said yeah well
just because men don't want to do it i
still don't think that makes women
special
just because like
i could ask i could do the same thing in
the street if you could get if you could
have a child without giving birth like
it's complicated didn't it it's
complicated did that same question and a
lot of the women said no if i didn't
have to give birth i could just have the
kid i would right
no one really i think
so but like the point is like we we hold
that on such high regard but
like
we all agreed raising a child is harder
and yet we still put women on this
pedestal because there's a lot of risk
given birth and
there's risk not anymore
historically there's risk in giving
birth now you're you're not you're not
scared of death when you go to that
like i've never heard of a man die of
fear during childhood women died during
childbirth right yeah but it's not just
women it's not the norm
i guess it used to be the risk is always
there
the risk is always there right but it
doesn't like to me
and then if 50 of women are hitting 30
and like they're predicting that 50 of
women between 25 and 45 will be single
and childless in the future like does
that make the women that don't have kids
not special
yeah would you say the less special
the childless women
but maybe your ability to give birth
makes you special if you don't use it
then if you do it or not it's like you
could that's what makes you special from
the men
that's what makes you different from the
men that you so because you're different
you're special do you not think right
yeah maybe the world is unique
yeah i would agree with unique
definitely yeah unique because it's
through us that you know
reproduction i don't know if if superman
could fly but he never flew yeah is he
special
yeah i think if they don't give birth
then you just he no he would be special
regardless if he flew on no because he's
the only person who could fly then
you're like you don't even know if he
can actually fly
she may not even be able to have kids
you don't know
what about the women that are barren
[Music]
then maybe just women are special
i don't know i don't know
you think so
when you were
i don't think women are special at all i
feel like we're i feel like we're told
we're special from a young age but we're
not i think the world is unique for me
so maybe specialist
how are you unique if you're 50 of the
population
i mean what your your ability is what
you're able to do by what you've been
told to do by nature yeah makes you
unique
yeah but then
half of women can do it it doesn't make
you that unique but i'm just saying
women in general like well like compared
to our minds i'm talking about a
particular word like one woman i said
women in general if they're able to
for the father it would be able to bring
life
that's that's unique do you think if
they invent artificial wombs
and
no and no longer need women to reproduce
why would a man need a woman i think
you'd be like you can start getting
syracula you know
breeding serial killers you need that um
child mother nurturing too you know you
can take that away yeah but you could
hire a nanny
and so
what to breastfeed the child
to take care of the child you could do
formula i'm just saying like that's what
they're saying nowadays like what what
does a man get from a woman that is
going to get from an artificial womb
companionship
i think a man and a woman needs each
other if you go
you know like woman doesn't need a man
or man artificial
we'll see
we'll see the you know the bad signs of
it yeah what do you think will happen if
that actually happens do you think men
will use it i think like you say more
women will be tomboys and more logical
but there'll be less
femininity and less softness in the
world i don't know yeah i think we'll
use that
i think i think the one out of three men
that are virgins or haven't had sex in
the last year i think they will
i feel like if you got no other option
like i do have a question for you paul
why do you think that's the case why why
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible